how's it going everybody it's Warren and
iron man / Tony Stark's last words not
only in Avengers in game but in his
entirety of the MCU where of course I am
Iron Man
the perfect way to end his story arc
coming back full circle to the very
first Iron Man film where Tony Stark
said I am Iron Man
iron man who started off the MCU would
finish the Infinity Saga and the first
11 years of the MCU saying these famous
last words saving the universe yes Iron
Man did record a message that was played
after he died and yes the final words in
the message were equally as awesome I
love you 3,000 but his last words while
he was alive where I am Iron Man but as
it turns out they almost weren't his
last words as it turns out Iron Man
initially wasn't even going to say I am
Iron Man but had a completely different
line right before he snapped and then
when they decided that he would say I am
Iron Man right before the snap he almost
said more when he was dying but Robert
Downey jr. said that he was not going to
say anything else I'll break down what
Tony Stark almost said in this video and
why Robert Downey jr. fought for Iron
Man's last words to be I am Iron Man
quick heads up at the 400,000 subscriber
mark I'll be doing a Marvel Legends
giveaway to enter you must be subscribed
to my channel and I'll talk more about
it at the end of this video so according
to the directors and the writers of
Avengers in game when Tony Stark got the
Infinity stones his words were almost fu
Fanus except he actually said the word
this would be the first f-bomb ever
dropped in the MCU ultimately they
decided to change it to I am Iron Man
I'm sure many fans would have gotten a
kick out of hearing Tony Stark saying a
few thin O's but ultimately I am Iron
Man was the perfect way for Tony Stark
to go out and Robert Downey jr. felt the
exact same way initially they had him
saying more while he was dying but
Robert Downey jr. put his foot down and
said that he's not going to say anything
else after he says I am Iron Man and in
a recent interview we found out why in a
recent interview director Joe Russo
commented on Tony Stark's last words I
am Iron Man
he said Robert was like I'm not going to
say effing anything I don't want to talk
because it doesn't feel honest to me
and I don't think in that moment that
he'd have the ability to speak
he was like I'm going to lay here and
you can let it unfold with other
characters but I'm going to barely
interact because that feels like a
truthful choice to me the directors
ultimately ended up a green and then
co-director Anthony Russo had this to
say to have a character in that much
pain on the verge of death it was
important for us to create the feeling
that when you looked at Tony Stark in
that moment you knew he was dying and
you had to process that in that moment
and I definitely think that that was a
major success I personally sat there
thinking this can't be it this can't be
when Tony Stark dies and you just sort
of sat there not thinking it was real
and then watched him die it was perfect
those were the perfect last words for
him to say because after we got the
recorded message that he left for Morgan
and pepper and it was very heartfelt and
it was a little bit more upbeat but I
absolutely think that Tony Stark not
saying anything after he snapped and
said I am Iron Man it was definitely the
way to go I think it had the most
emotional impact and I think everybody
is going to remember that moment for the
rest of their lives so kudos to you
Robert Downey jr. for sticking to your
guns but let me know what you all think
about this do you think that this was
the way to go or do you think that he
should have said something else after I
am Iron Man or would you have rather
heard him say a few Fanus let me know
what you prefer in the comments down
below and again another reminder about
my giveaway when I hit 450,000
subscribers I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection to enter all you have to do
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain be sure to follow me on social
media as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your